what's the difference between tai chi
and qigong i often get asked this
question so let's explore a little bit
both the differences and the
similarities of these practices
historically qigong is about 5 000 years
old
it's an ancient practice coming from
chinese medicine
chi means life force energy it's your
aliveness and gong means to work with
or to develop a skill at working with
that life force energy
now qigong was broken down into three
distinct styles
one was medical qigong how to work with
energy for health
wellness and vitality the other was
spiritual qigong
how to feel that connection to the
divine maybe meditation practices the
energy of consciousness and the mind and
spirit
and the third was martial art style of
qigong how do you work with energy to
develop a powerful body
now tai chi falls into that third branch
of
martial arts style of qigong practice so
we can say
that qigong was the mother of tai chi it
gave birth to tai chi practice
and tai chi is a very specific practice
for martial
application but both of these practices
have
unique and similar principles for
example both practices move from the
center
both practices are water-like they're
internal
arts they both cultivate energy now the
intention of both practices
is to develop and cultivate that energy
for
health and vitality and internal power
and then tai chi what it does is it
moves into a martial expression
for example tai chi every movement in
tai chi is going to have a martial
application
a block and a strike and
one movement in the tai chi form will
then go into another movement
so in tai chi you have to learn a whole
sequence of movements
108 style or a 64 movement style
now there's three or four distinct
styles in tai chi maybe there's a few
more
and there's 3 000 styles of qigong
so there's a lot of different styles so
tai chi would be considered a
one particular style of qigong practice
the marshall style that originated from
chen family that's
the story in the history of tai chi
about 800 years ago
chen family practitioners were doing
chen style
tai chi and they had a servant as the
story goes
named yang and yang would
spy and watch and take notes and
practice
what he was witnessing in the chen
family so master chen was teaching his
sons
but the servant yang was practicing and
he practiced very
strongly and developed a high skill at
the tai chi
martial arts practice and then master
yang
took it to his family so now we have
young style and chen
style some varieties of movements a lot
of them are similar
but there's some distinct styles now tai
chi became very popularized because
in that young family lineage the martial
arts practitioners became very
good and they would challenge martial
arts schools around the country
until they became very famous
for their martial skill and the chinese
emperor and the royal guard learned
a short style of yang family tradition
tai chi
and it became popularized now mainly we
practice tai chi for the same reasons we
practice qigong
we practice for health energy
cultivation for stress manage it
management and for feeling that deep
connection to our internal energy and
power
now what i recommend is that you
practice
qigong first because it's simpler it's
more accessible you learn how to move
your energy
you learn about these principles how do
i move with relaxation how do i move
with water like softness
and then we can start to move those same
principles into a tai chi form
because the tai chi form you're going to
have to memorize different
sequences of movements because one
movement will go right into the next
whereas in qigong one movement
flows in a rhythmic pattern and repeats
itself as a moving meditation
and it becomes easier to practice so for
example
this movement here parting the horse's
mane will repeat itself
over and over in a qigong practice where
in tai chi that movement
you do it in a walking set where you're
going to be
moving the energy into a form which
makes it harder
to memorize so for me after 30 years of
practice
what i like to do is i like to first
learn qigong learn all the principles
and then i like to teach people tai chi
afterwards as
those applications of those principles
well if you're interested in learning
about your own life force energy
how to transform stress into vitality
how to use energy to cultivate
health well-being longevity as this
practice was designed
we have an offer for you we have a free
two-week trial
that means you're going to get about 10
classes to try it for yourself
in these 10 classes you will feel
your life force energy it's a different
experience you'll feel energy moving in
your body
and that aliveness feels wonderful it's
empowering
it's empowering to you to take charge of
your own
health and vitality so if you want to
try
please click the button below enter your
name and your email address
and you will get free two-week trial of
this
weekly subscription and from there
sometimes we do
a little bit of tai chi but it's a great
foundation to then branch off
into a tai chi practice also if you like
the information that you're getting in
this youtube channel
click the subscribe button we'll have a
lot more content just like
this and if you want to get notified
click the little bell
and we will send you out more content
just like this hey thanks so much and
we'll see you in the next video